à l'école primaire de morne calebasse
c'est branle bas de combat tous les
recoins de l'établissement sont astiquer
récurer depuis plusieurs semaines des
élèves sont privés de cours le maire de
fort de france a dû user de son autorité
pour débloquer les accès il ya eu des
remontées aussi des parents d'élèves qui
doivent trouver des situations départ
par exemple de demander le service
minimum au maire mais c'est difficile
puisque ce service minimum se fait dans
les écoles qui sont bloqués là loin
indiquant qu' un certain nombre
d'enseignants absents le mérite tenu à
l'euro exige non mais est tenu de
proposer effectivement par un service
minimum mais qui se fait dans les écoles
mais comme là c'est un cas assez
particulier les écoles sont bloqués donc
le maire n'a pas les moyens de réaliser
ce qu'on a les agents qui travaillent
donc qui aurait pu l'assumé côté
syndicat le préavis de grève contre la
réforme des retraites pour toujours ce
matin nous avons rencontré des
représentants de l'unsa et de la cgtm
soem lemery dans ses prérogatives distel
mais la grèce n'est pas fini mais il est
remarquable dans l'art l'école qui crie
et nous les ovins établissements mais
malheureusement 1008 tellement à
l'entrée du portail et au ballon et
passe à ces risques l'aqsiq les
auriniens réunion et puis nous prendrons
part la suter ce que nous disons là pour
aujourd'hui c'est qu'il ya un grand
nombre d'établissements qui sont
confirmées d'une part et que lorsque les
établissements ouvrent il y a également
des coûts des questions d'hygiène et de
sécurité qui se posent donc il faut que
toutes ces conditions là soient réunies
pour savoir si les établissements du
premier degré pourront fonctionner donc
là aujourd'hui nous sommes dans la tente
37 écoles primaires de fort de france
devrait ouvrir demain matin
mais pour combien de temps des syndicats
annoncent une mobilisation dans la rue
ce jeudi 20 février